it was terrifying
I could really see everything as it was
about to happen they came intentionally
to beat people up they brought their
stakes they were ready for a fight so it
was clear that were more danger from the
right fingers than there was from these
incoming rockets and if you survived
demonstration you'd have people
following you after it we have nowhere
to go you have no nowhere to run because
if you run they start chasing you
and people were chased down the streets
and it ended up that evening with one
demonstrator from the anti war can
hospitalize and several others wounded
going out and demonstrating against the
wards not as easy as it used to be
right-wing extremists that came to beat
up the people demonstrating against the
war and in several times succeeded to do
so because police did not prevent them
from doing so and in other events the
police itself decided the demonstration
is illegal and attack and made arrests
my name is a guy metallo I'm a
journalist and an activist and I
participate and write about the protests
you have demonstrators in the middle of
the city chanting slogans that are
critical of the army and are against the
war effort it's a time when there's a
lot of emotion going on the common
message that these people have is that
we have to paint so the Arabs and the
Israel haters green and send them into
the sewage not only must you shut up we
should also pluck your eyes out and cut
your tongue once you would have people
sending messages to to activists saying
we know who you are and we'll beat you
up but that didn't really happen then
suddenly people actually are followed
when the riba demonstration they are
four words of their homes and beaten up
it's another in a series of protests
against the current war in gaza in the
very last minute the police announced
that would not allow people to
demonstrate allegedly because it is
dangerous for more than 1,000 people to
be in one place because of rocket
threats there were several thousand
people planned to come and i hope that
there will be 500 people today which
will be a lot considering the fact that
police just canceled the event
the rhetoric of parliamentarians
mainstream journalism has been that the
joint arab-jewish left that is critical
of the occupation is not a legitimate
part of society
my name is Lambie tell Stella this is
our turf a my husband and I in his realm
dangerous we passed by the demonstration
there was the two sites and I went on a
little hill to take pictures to see what
what's happening - I do - find her and
found out that she was bitten and was
attacked I heard someone say oh man I'm
lefty and I don't think you know me so
why don't wanna kill me and hear me for
a second time all hell broke loose her
friend pulled my hair and she just
jumped on me I felt like pulling my hair
bidding my hand they pour beer on me and
they smashed and they bowed my head and
I was lying on the floor hiding my face
not to get bitten I found the extra ones
of a placement - from that hundred
right-winger men shouted she's a war
she's a Palestinian war kill all the
Palestinians were killed on the left is
whore really wish me to die maybe only a
really tiny percent of the population
thinks that the war is wrong I don't
take the Israeli actions in the Gaza is
something sacred something holy you know
from their point of view
I should ask questions that you're just
a great fascist don't ask questions
don't warrants to depart indentures
I refused to join the army that was 12
years ago I spent two years in prison it
was a military prison in the beginning
and then they got tired of us there and
said we were bad influence and other
inmates and they kicked us out to a
civilian prison it wasn't a good time it
was a very difficult time but yeah came
through going on military campaigns in
Gaza
time after time just isn't working and I
think people are very depressed by that
because they they're being told by the
media this is a very just war this is
the right solution this is the only way
to guarantee peace and then that doesn't
work first of all I'm a rapper and my
music started from patriotism first of
all I did it in the music now we took it
no 16:7 soldiers in a as mehmet pasha
beaten Tsar Bomba NASA the McCutcheon
over the face
after that we'll be like em for cheap no
no sir
name is Jehan jihad and spokesman for
organizations all the Lions this is the
most democratic country in the world we
believe in the freedom of speech if you
believe that we're doing something
you're wrong gives you the right the
lion is the symbol of unity and the
Jewish religion and this is why we are
the lion show me another country in the
time war allows any voice that's want to
be heard
demonstrate show me another country in
the world that won't throw you in jail
for what you're demonstrating these
people say that we are violating human
rights this is the proper definition of
prison because they go against the media
army against the military against our
own right to defend ourselves
a Jewish girl there is Miriam and the
radical right that are going to protest
and they are very violent from the left
are going to be there to marry now all
coming from all around Israel and but
most of them are settlers from the West
Bank when there was the war and we
wanted to protest for all sorts of you
know excuses and reasons they didn't let
the leftist protest because of you know
security reasons so-called and now when
this couple wants to get married they
can do the same they can just tell them
guys you're not allowed to protest you
they let them do this it's horrifying
really and it says a lot about what's
going on in Israel becoming so radical
and it's scary it's scary we feel
ourselves as lefties that we are not
safe here in Israel in the sense
that side is an organization called lava
against the simulation in the Holy Land
Sharia law says that the husband must
hit his wife - educator and the Jewish
laws that says that every woman is a
queen okay this is the Western
civilization and the Muslim civilization
it's not the same it's not the same this
is why the Lions are not so I am white
is the best in the world
they say they oppose the girls that's an
excuse it's a racist group of people
that wants the Jewish race to become a
democracy it's all about balance it
doesn't work when you have radicals
sitting in your government seems like
the right will always win so many people
have left and were just a little group
now so it's getting a bit dangerous for
us because they are looking for us
seriously Phil Israel is going down the
drain in so many words in so many senses